after the 98 Arnold I get a phone call
would you be interested in working with
Sean ray why would he say well I'm gonna
tell you why he said that my athletes
literally change sport
they looked different everybody has
access to certain things Kuwait
yeah the anabolic chicken everything
it's probably right now the most abuse
drug in the sport this suppose Dallas
McCarver anabolic non-canonical right I
don't know if people even believe this
you know he's speaking everybody outside
of Haney and Yates you're saying there's
no way even if you work with him that he
could win the whole thing look I think
he's a piece of [ __ ] person I'm not
gonna deny that he was a good body go
Kevin LeBron was like angered and he was
like this mad man dripping in sweat and
rips his shirt off and he's ready to
fight me that's a complete lie
that's media that's conversation that's
talk so then Steve Weinberger he's like
dude you gotta chill out like this is
not the place so the part about Kevin
wanted to rip you a new one well there's
a marshal truth to that yeah the more
angry Sean got the more driven I became
I would have probably worked with every
one of his competitors for free just to
bury him did you ever think you would
you phone we got that tape now you came
in give it values today this world of
entrepreneurs we can't no value to hate
this run homie look what I become I'm
the unborn
[Music]
so I got to tell you I remember when I
interviewed Sammy the bull Gravano and
when I interviewed Sammy Sammy called
that Teddy Atlas a month later Teddy
Atlas sat right here and he said listen
I got a respond to what Sammy said I
remember when we had Dorian Yates here
and he called that Brandon curry a month
later Brandon curry showed up and
responded to Dorian
however Shawn Ray calls out chat Nichols
Chad showed up in the front doorstep
here within 24 hours so would that be in
such an thanks for coming out I
appreciate you having me so I'm assuming
that video with our buddy Shawn really
fired you up a little it did a little
bit it wasn't anything that I wasn't
used to but it is you know when you wake
up in the morning and you have 25 DMS
with a clip of Shawn's at it again you
get a little irritated was it anything
different than what he had said in the
past before it really wasn't there was
mostly the same stuff but there was a
couple things within it that was like
JustFab completely fabricated which was
kind of shocking like I'm not even sure
why he went down the road but because it
didn't pertain to like him bashing me
but like it was again completely
fabricated so how about I played I got a
part of it I'm not gonna play the whole
thing they'll give you six minutes I got
the fifty second part of it and then we
can go from there and obviously I got a
lot of other topics I want to go into
with you but let's start off with our
buddy here by the way
the UN Chad nickels ever do anything
together absolutely not he's dr.
Kevorkian to me bro
in 1996 I went to guest pose for him
took me to dinner and he asked me if I
needed any help
I just got second place to Dorian Yates
no I don't need your help I don't even
know you and I think that's where we
started to butt heads Ronnie Coleman
will defend him to the ninth degree but
he was in that bathtub near death in
2001 at the direction of Chad Nichols
who's not a doctor by the way there's at
least five deaths Don Youngblood NASA
relson body Dallas McCarver and few
other people as a bodybuilding coach
that are dead and in the ground and he
hadn't gone to one funeral so I have a
reason to be pissed so that's a shorter
abbreviated version of you know of what
he said exactly what are your thoughts
somebody said there so there's a couple
things I it depends where you want me to
start we can start from the beginning
the most I don't know if I want to say
funny because I don't think any of its
funny but the most interesting part of
it and it basically outlines basically
his direction of the whole thing is
right from the get-go because he says
you asked him if we ever worked together
and his response was absolutely not but
he went in guest post for me in 96 and I
asked him if he wanted to work with me
or basically that's we had that's a
complete lie
like that's an absolute lie and when I
explained it to you you'll understand he
did absolutely guest post for me that
year he came he guest posed we went out
to eat we that was literally the first
time that I'd probably talking to him I
didn't even know if he was in town until
I got to the venue and there was a
Lamborghini parked out in front of the
venue that some guy from Arkansas had
brought down for him to drive around
town all day he guest posed I didn't
have any issues there we go out to eat
and we literally talked about three
things we talked about his like which
was weird because I was actually under
the impression he was from a very
wealthy family but he kind of portrayed
the fact that his brother was a drug
addict and his mother was in prison for
drugs and which means my wife were kind
of like what we thought he was from very
like wealthy family so we're kind of
shocked by that
no big deal and then he kind of
portrayed this MA
of him like really working out of the
gutters and coming you know becoming to
think which I like again like we don't
know it like by at all I don't know him
at all at that time the bodybuilding
world doesn't know him yet oh no they
know him but we do don't know we don't
know I don't know him from man he say we
zoom in Kim okay we don't know anything
about him we was just under the
impression
pression that he was from a very wealthy
family just based off of how he day he
was maybe portrayed in the magazines
which is really the only way we know it
he talked a little bit about the cars
how this guy would sell him the cars he
would buy the car driver for two months
resell it which I thought was kind of a
cool idea and then he basically talked
about finances that was the only thing
we talked about now here's the
interesting thing we didn't talk about
nutrition we didn't talk about athletes
I was working with we didn't talk about
anything about that the reason we didn't
talk about that is because I wasn't
working with athletes yet I hadn't
trained anyone the only person I had
trained up until that point is Kim from
92 to 96
I don't first get involved in nutrition
until the 97 Olympia
at no point would there ever be a
conversation of a kid I was 27 years old
whatever I don't know 28 9 years old I
would never be even talking in that
realm because I wasn't there yet like
nobody's talking about hey Chad Nicholas
is working with athletes he's you know
doing this he's doing that that part
hasn't even started
it's a year down the road so that is
completely fabricated 100% completely
fabricated in no way shape or form did
that never happen why would he say well
I'm gonna tell you why he said that
because I never asked him but now we
fast forward so in 97 I do start working
with athletes okay and I trained NASA
relson body mm-hmm I trained Paul to let
both of them gone most people think the
NASA could have won the Olympia that
year Dorian ends up winning but no
matter what it was the best that NASA
had ever looked that year 98 we come to
the Arnold Classic
and flex wheeler wins now a lot of
people will say that to his best ever
I think his two best is his first 193
where he was a little smaller but
conditioning was phenomenal and 98 which
he was bigger and again conditioning
phenomenal directly after the 98 Arnold
now this is where everybody's gonna this
is gonna be interesting
after the 98 Arnold I get a phone call
from Boyer Co now if you're familiar
with Boyer Co Sean ray and Boyer Co they
had a workout program called flex
workout together so they were friends he
also dated a girl named Debbie mug Lee
who was a professional bodybuilder my
wife and Debbie mug Lee were friends so
when we would go out to California we go
out to eat with Boyer and Debbie and we
became friends
Boyer CO calls me and says listen Chet
would you be interested in working with
Shawn ray because the Olympia is open
this year and we believe that with your
guidance he could win the Olympia and so
at this point I'm kind of like okay
because I'd already started hearing like
little tidbits of stuff that was
starting to come like after the flex
wheeler when at the Arnold right that
was all kind of being directed at Shawn
but the rumors right because at this
point we have no social media everything
is just hearsay Jeff and stuff and again
this can all be literally confirmed
through Boyer Co so so Boyer calls me to
ask me this and I'm like listen honestly
there has to be three things that has to
factor in for me to work with an athlete
one I have to believe they're a hard
worker to I have to believe that they'll
pay attention and do exactly what I say
there that I'm not wasting my time with
the athlete and three I have to believe
that we are going to click and that the
person is not a like that he's a decent
human being
Shawn doesn't match any of the three
criteria I have zero interest in working
with him zero told us to to Boyer Co now
on that prior to this how many
interactions have you had with Shawn
none except for that dinner yes oh I
take that back I take that back actually
so
we're at the dinner so now at the dinner
supposedly this is when I supposedly
asked him right and he's like Oh
Chad's the devil right like we don't
want anything to do with him but in 97
when my wife wins the Olympia we are in
California for photo shoots and we're
doing photo shoots and miraculously
Shawn shows up at the photo shoot like
out of the blue for no reason
shows up at the show at the photo shoot
and there's literally like somehow even
gets into the photo shoot so there's
literally a picture of him like
encouraging Kim to like you know like
how they're doing photos and they're
like go for the weight and like Kim's
curling and he's like motivating her
stuff so he literally shows up there now
again I don't talk with him we don't
talk about anything were like at no
point are we talking about working
nothing
like literally he just shows up which I
thought was weird no the reason why or
never no idea okay literally got no idea
why showed up but it would be it seems
odd that he would show up there based on
the fact that he just told you in 96
that like I'm the devil and he wouldn't
have anything to do with me when in
reality I can tell you that never
happened the whole thing was completely
fabricated by Shawn completely
fabricated by Shawn and after that point
if you realize that was after the 98
Arnold from that point I became the
devil for sure so from that point
everything literally escalated so once I
had talked to Boyer that seems to be the
point because before that there's no
interaction there's no Chad this Chad
that blablablabla after that point
that's when everything Escalus after you
taught Boyer no chance no no chance
Angeline Boyer could confirm that he's
100% now I've had people like talk to
Boyer and Boyer will kind of beat around
the bush a little bit about it he will
confirm that he made the phone call he
will confirm and he will kind of act
like you know well so I didn't really
come out and say like to do it but I was
just reaching out on his behalf I don't
buy that for a second they were buddies
like not for a second do I buy that
because at this point now we're already
like by the time this is already be an
ass Shawn's already like
bashing the hell out of me so I think he
realizes it's happened he can't go back
on that it happened obviously but he has
to kind of save face for Shawn a little
now at this point who's working with you
flex is working with you [ __ ] names
that are working I was working with you
yeah so this is 98 now I have Nasir I
have flex I have Ronnie I have pulled to
let those are probably the mean those
are they and those are names but those
are not like years they're working with
the main guys pretty much at 98 I mean
the 90 - yeah the 98 Olympia that was
the top three it was Ronnie flex and
Nasir and in the 99 Olympia it was
Ronnie flex Cormier and I had Cormier in
99 Cormier as well yes okay 99 it was
the first year in the other part of what
he says is how would led to you know or
what happened with Nasir how he led to
what happened with the rest of the name
but it's absolutely okay what's your
response to what he says about so
there's a cut there's a bunch of
response like we can we can talk about
it but I think the biggest one is flex I
think that basically sets the tone for
just how big of a liar Shawn is like he
is a pathological liar and anybody
that's listening to this right now can
go to Google and they can type in what
disease was flex wheeler born with and
it will pull up FSGS which is focal
segmental whatever okay it's a kidney
disease that he was born okay he didn't
find out about that until 99 now Shawn
is a hundred percent aware of this he's
a hundred percent aware of it I don't
recall ever in my 20 years that he's
been talking [ __ ] about me ever hearing
him mention it but he's a hundred
percent aware of what the diseases that
flex has a hundred percent but he looked
at you dead in the eye and basically
blamed me for a disease that Flex has
now here's the bad part of it flex went
through a kidney transplant he has this
disease but it's a disease that he got
at birth he still has it so the kidney
transplant didn't cure flex this is
something that flex will have to go
through
ever so 15 years from now
now I'm granted no flex is aware of it
now so he was very proactive he is
watching everything they monitor
everything but that's not to say that in
15 years because the disease is there
destroying the kidney right now it's
there it's destroying the kidney and in
15 years flex may end up needing another
kidney like that's possible because of
that now could've bodybuilding escalated
that a hundred percent okay there's no
doubt it's you're not discounting it I
absolutely not
like listen if he would have chose to be
a golfer he probably would have needed a
kidney transplant ten years later but he
didn't he didn't choose that he chose to
be a bodybuilder and it doesn't matter
what you know what I did what he did it
did it doesn't matter because based off
of the chosen sport it was going to
escalate the problem and I'm sure that
flex is a hundred percent aware of that
it isn't because he did extreme things
it isn't because he done more than the
other person or less than the other
person it's because of the sport in
general but at the end of the day the
reason he is missing a kidney or had a
kidney transplant is because he was born
unfortunately with FSGS and that's and
like I said I can promise you you can
google that what was he you know and it
will literally be the first thing that
pops up and again it's not like Shawn
didn't know that he's a hundred percent
aware of it but if he says you know he
was born with a kidney transplant and
this and that did it up that doesn't
really create drama but if he uses my
name and slams me then people like [ __ ]
like that's a whole different story
but if he's been doing this all year
long there's got to be a sincere because
he also said some will come back to the
names here in a minute and we'll go
through some of the pictures that we got
here but he also mentioned dawn long -
yeah he mentioned how long he mentioned
all these names so but but the part the
part that I want to go to is is before
we get into that
he also said Kevin LeBron was heated and
yet wanted to be sure not because he was
setting exactly tear you a new one right
so because there's two camps again
before we get into this
I want to play something on what Ronnie
said about yoga flex it about you
because the overall story at least is
has got some partial truth to it so
there is some part there's a partial
truth to that didn't unfortunately play
out let me play this let's watch what
Ronnie and flake say about you
we heard Charlotte say what they say she
was your nutritionist plate and winning
it's you know how had he not had a night
hand I wouldn't want that big of a role
that bigger role was that the same one
those eight years when you went back to
bed on same woman how much trust did you
have in his feedback 1,000% trust I did
every single thing he told me did you
got it what's here nutritionist for
multiple people or only you multiple
people
okay flex flex one told me to go to his
this Chad you're talking about yet
Nichols okay said Nichols Wow
not sure where I'd be without him yeah
taught me a lot in an age of gurus he
taught me that flex you know more about
you than me the only reason I can help
you is if you understand your body well
enough to explain it to me
that I can give you advice
so polar opposites okay one camp is anti
checker sure one camp swears by user
that it's not he didn't even say 100% he
said 1,000% right one camp swears by you
one camp doesn't he says the camp with
him lover because obviously when this
interview went live with Sean and what
he said you know the comments he made
about are you sure you know my my phone
from bodybuilders from all the way you
can't believe this he's right you go let
me say what so I'm kind of like from the
other I'm not even in the bottom now
this is not my game I'm gonna complete
it from game but I watched a practice
thing and I noticed automatics like
Democrat some Republican and there's
those in the middle right I'm just kind
of stay one out of there's a partially
right partially not so let's first
address the live wrong thing then we can
come back what some of these guys it so
the part about Kevin wanted to rip you
knew one was I was that partially right
no okay but there was a confrontation so
here's what happens so we this is the
first this is 98 so the show is in New
York so me and Kim fly and we get in
late so we are literally coming in at
the end of the press conference so we're
literally getting ready to or it's
actually kind of the athletes meeting
it's kind of before they have like
literally a press conference it's more
of a like an athlete's meeting so
they're discussing everything kind of
amongst themselves and it's not really
an open thing there's media in there
there's people in there but it's not
like it is today and so we're walking in
there and everybody's like bro you do
not want to go in there like this whole
thing was about you and I'm like what do
you what do you mean it was about me and
I'm like like dude they're literally
ripping you a new [ __ ] and I'm like
so I'm like oh yeah who's they
so that's all they said so we don't know
we don't know who it is yet right so we
walk in that were originally thinking
like okay we we got we know it's Sean we
know Sean's involved but we don't know
all the players yet so we get in and I'm
met by Paul delet and flex wheeler just
to get the baits right this is this most
your call would Boyer this is post yes
this is after okay yes okay yes all
right so so we're met we're walking in
so we just literally walk in to the
press conference
and it's over so everybody's kind of
made it into groups they're talking to
press their stuff we walk in and pull
delet and flex beeline over to me and
they're like bro like i don't know
what's going on but man this was crazy
and like they wanted you like your room
searched and like all the stuff and I'm
like yeah I'm cool with that lease
whatever they want and they're like
they're talking about a black bag well
the black bag was actually a little
fanny pack that I wore this all the time
like back in the day I like I literally
no matter where I have there's a picture
of me there's like a fanny pack on and
I'm like listen they can search it right
now like I don't have a problem with
that and they're like but yes so this is
what all went down and Kevin laronne
said that you called him and literally
told him he ain't got a chance in hell
of placing in the Olympia without me
okay now I lose my [ __ ] now like um like
piss because up until this point Kevin
Love roan is not even on the radar like
literally not on the radar so now I'm
pissed and so I happened to just catch
out of the corner of my eye Kevin Love
roan walking kind of the outskirts of
the ballroom so I just literally meet
him like immediately and I'm like dude
what what the [ __ ] is this like what is
this like I'm hearing that like I called
you and he's like bro bro no it was
misunderstood like it was Wayne it was
Wayne and I'm like so now I think he's
lying to me now I literally flip out
like literally flip out and I'm like
like literally throwing f-bombs and I'm
like dude I'll beat your ass right here
okay so I'm like at this point like I'm
gonna tighten this one Kevin Kevin
LeBron i'ma beat his ass right there so
he's got a training partner behind him
so I'm probably 300 pounds right here
who's this training partner behind who
is also probably 300 pounds right so he
steps up but he's like what did you say
and so now I'm like screaming back and
forth like and we're literally three
seconds from going like we're getting
ready to go who's on your side right now
Paul they let it fly back there like Kim
is trying to stay between us like I'm
screaming like LeBron is right there but
through the whole time LeBron is like
bro this is a misunderstanding like this
is not you know like I didn't say that
like
it was waned Emilia did it edited up but
then you know like the training part of
steps in so then Steve Weinberger like
literally grabs me and it's like dude
you gotta chill out like and I'm like
man I'm tired of the [ __ ] I'm fed up
with these you know guys running their
mouth like I'm gonna beat their [ __ ]
ass right here shut the door and he's
like dude you got to chill out like this
is not the place and I'm like all right
you're right this is not right
so now if you have a relationship with
them outside like are you guys good you
and Eve yes yes I grab me how about
Wayne just to put it all together
Wayne's a different story okay doesn't
like when they don't but at the time
they were kind of coke
you know 98 right okay and so big Steve
grabs me he's like dude you know how
this is people talk like you know he
calms me down you got to stop the [ __ ]
blah blah it's not the time I realize it
so literally like we were three seconds
from just you know 600 pounds of
stupidity like you know bouncing around
in the ballroom of the you know wouldn't
be a press conference like just an idiot
really basically that's what you know
and so at the whole weekend though like
they literally assigned a security guard
to live round so the security guard with
him and I'm thinking like and so I tell
Steve like dude like really like they're
like that just for precautions they know
you're pissed and all this and I'm like
like I was pissed like 30 minutes ago
I'm not pissed now what reputation deal
at this time do you have attempt a
reputation of somebody that loses it the
are you mean really are you a chill guy
are you like an underground chill guy
but like everybody knew who my friends
were like everybody knew who I like they
like they knew like who I ran with as an
bodybuilder fronts of friends like God
some scary friends yeah and so but I
don't think that was really I think it
was just you were connected in a way
that they knew yes yes not cross and not
yeah I don't know about that I just
think that everybody was at that time
like hey listen you know this is what we
do and this is what's gonna happen if
this is what you know if this goes down
okay now as the weekend goes on it
becomes very apparent that Kevin LeBron
didn't have [ __ ] to do with anything
okay so now so literally it didn't have
anything to do it kept like it was
literally Wayne d'emilia in Sean ray
like back and forth just stirring the
pot and it became very apparent of that
right off the bat and I literally I
didn't do it that weekend because
obviously I stayed completely away from
Kevin Love roam because obviously it was
competing the last thing I wanted to do
was create a more of a you know [ __ ]
drama for him but later on I absolutely
apologized to him told him like look man
I'd totally lost my [ __ ] but that was
because of Sean like I literally should
have never done that it was a wrong time
wrong place like it was idiotic
you know type of thing me and Kevin
shook hands we never ever had a problem
ever again from that ever no I get along
which with human communication we Kevin
I don't communicate with him but I'm not
you know if Megan got a message saying
hey did you see the interview happened
that we don't communicate back and forth
like that but like when he was making a
comeback you know I you know I reached
out to him like dude you know I love
this you know I can't wait to see on
stage type of thing we were friendly
with you know in no way shape or form
where I say were friends but like you
know we're friendly with each other and
I have a lot of respect for him and I
and I would to this day say like that
you know me jumping the gun that was
100% my fault like I just lost my [ __ ]
because of all the stuff that had you
know went on and that's what happened
but at no point did Kevin LeBron like
rip his shirt off like again like that
is so like far-fetched and and literally
there was 20 people around like there
was 20 people standing around watching
the whole thing which for Shawn to say
is literally delusional like that's the
part that like is crazy and the part
that is weird and and I was a cop for
five years and people that lie all the
time
literally when they lie to their spouses
or to their employers that they do it
all the time they end up blurring
reality and the lie and so they just
don't understand him because the lie is
usually what rotates in their head
most of the time they don't know the
truth they don't understand the truth
they don't know where the truth is so
for him to literally come up with
that you know Kevin LeBron was like
angered and he was like this madman
dripping in sweat he rips his shirt off
and he's ready to fight me was literally
idiotic like idiotic and and really like
yeah I lost my cool and but it was
actually probably closer to me and the
trading partner getting into it because
the training partner ended up stepping
forward and that was literally more of
it and Steve Weinberger broke the entire
thing up
you know like pulled me off calmed me
down sent me on my way we and everything
was fine like it was over with that me
and again
me and Kevin never had another problem
after that ever when's the last time you
knew Sean spoke spoke spoke spoke so me
and Dan Salomon done a radio podcast
called pro bodybuilding Chi weekly and I
believe he was on there
this is how long ago this has been eight
years ago eight years ago
Wow it's been Shawn haven't talked
anytime soon outside of that eight years
have you had any kind of interaction any
dinner or lunch with nothing zero no
nothing nothing that's public people
know you and Shawn are on different
absolutely okay 100% so let me ask you a
question who else would agree because
yesterday I was reading some of the
posts and people were tagging me and I
saw what a couple people posted Sameer
posted would announce it and all these
guys and I was kind of being the Samara
one - yeah so I'm getting I'm getting
all this stuff and I'm you again I'm
Reid I'm like okay good okay this person
saying this then there was a lot of
people involved the time we got involved
jQuery on Samus I forgot all so their
camp if they're saying that was there
anybody that was worried about you
getting close to the other guys like
there was a story about they were trying
to get everybody to be tested I do
because it was the open is there truth
behind that part would they would I mean
they were absolutely trying to get it
tested
yes they're trying to get the guys in
your camp tested they they wanted the
whole show tested I believe because they
were under the impression that my guys
had an unfair advantage so that's where
like the plasma expanders stuff stories
you know we became and so they wanted
they basically wanted a blood test for
plasma expanders because they thought
that would even the playing field and
the funny story of that is so waned
Amelia calls me like before the Olympia
and it's talking to me and he says
listen we're gonna test we're gonna
blood test at the at the Olympia and I'm
like it's all right and they're like
we're gonna blood test for plasma
expanders and I'm like okay and he's
like you know so I just wanted to let
you know and I'm like listen do you you
realize that none of my guys are using
plasma expanders I go I said if you knew
anything about plasma expanders you
would realize that to use them you
actually need a diuretic so a plasma
expander will pull water into the blood
but you still have to be able to get rid
of the water so I said what you need to
do is there's five diuretics that you
realize aren't on the diuretic list
right I said if you're going to test for
the plasma expanders and you literally
want to make this a hundred percent add
the five diuretics and he's like well
we're comfortable with the diuretic test
we're just concerned about the plasma
expanders now the five diuretics that
were very common off the diuretic test
was clearly what everybody was going to
use nobody needed plasma expanders
because there was already diuretics that
was available to him that wasn't going
to be tested so the whole thing the
whole staged like check his bag and all
of this kind of stuff was idiotic
because in reality
Wayne 2-million knew that there was
tests that there was a diuretics off the
test to begin with not only did he know
he literally told certain athletes like
hey listen most of the athletes are
using this diuretic because it's not on
the list like it was very well known
very well know very well don't worry so
why is he calling you though what is so
yeah it was it is is that the world
where everyone knows who the
you know the the Chad nickels is because
there's names of a mountain that people
use are there's you know the names that
are okay are they very close in
communication with folks like when Wayne
words okay here's what we're looking at
this you're know that was a one-off
thing that happened it was well I mean
it was when that you know the whole
diuretic thing took place but I think
that what ended up happening was my
athletes literally changed sport like
they looked different like they were in
better shape
they were drier they were more
conditioned and literally the people
were like obviously if that's the way
they look there has to be something he
has to have something that is clearly
not available to everybody else like and
that's I believe what you know and so I
don't necessarily know they ever had
planned on diary you know I mean blood
testing because there would be just and
monumental you know undertaking I think
the whole thing was they were trying to
be like well maybe he does have
something so we're gonna scare the [ __ ]
out of him and I am NOT a me okay yeah
and so well you know is he am I gonna be
this am I gonna be that but in reality
there never was anything there whatever
whatever happened to you we're not gonna
do anything to you or no nothing
can you go to do you go to miss roll up
here every year every year you're there
absolutely and how are you treated when
you go there but just like normal normal
guy this absolutely no one's given you a
hard time any of that snow okay
so are there any other people that have
bad relationships with you at the level
of Shawn or Nell I don't think so
nothing not that people know the
marketplace I mean don't know I mean
there's there's no doubt I think that
even you know when you come out with
this like listen I could I could give
you every possible scenario of why Shawn
lied but at the end of the day there's
gonna be people that like me and they
will believe me and there's gonna be
people that like Shawn they will believe
him but at the end of it all Shawn is
literally the one that had the biggest
heart on for me and it was very obvious
why he did because like he said he just
like you said in 96 you know I didn't I
didn't need anybody's help because I
play second to Dorian Yates actually
placed third but Nasir flunked the
redick test which then moved him into
second place and like you know he was
like you know this is this is you know
who I am type of thing but unfortunately
he never placed in the top three ever
again ever and my guys beat him from
that point on like without a doubt and
the more angry he got the more driven I
became and the more like like I mean
there was a point where potentially I
would have probably worked with every
one of his competitors for free just to
bury him let me ask you a different
question here's a question for you say
he did work with you let's just say yes
let's just say you've got your story his
story everybody's gonna hear but let's
just say you know somebody came in says
listen let's just try to make this work
let's just say you did would he have had
a chance to win it all no no that's it
that's a strong statement because he's
been second he's been top five thirty
competitions you know he's speaking
everybody outside of Haney and Yates
you're saying there's in no way even if
you work with him that it could win the
whole thing no chance why is that here's
the thing so during the time frame that
I would have came in from 97 on ya flex
wheeler is also in the mix and Ronnie
Coleman is in the mix and I can tell you
that Shawn Ray at a hundred percent
doesn't beat either one of those guys at
ninety percent no chance and is he is he
a good bodybuilder look I think he's a
piece of [ __ ] person I'm not gonna deny
that he was a good bodybuilder like ever
like of course she was a good
bodybuilder but was he a flex wheeler
bodybuilder no he wasn't a flex wheeler
body bull he didn't have the genetics of
flex wheeler he didn't have anything
close to that was he close to Ronnie :
look nobody's close to Ronnie Coleman at
hundred percent nobody I don't care what
anybody says they can idolize whoever
they want Ronnie if you look at Ronnie
in 2003 we may never see that again ever
like I mean if we do it will be
amazing sight but he was that far ahead
of everybody that far ahead so if you
work with you again let me take this
back I know you weren't in 1996 but the
two years where he got he was right
behind yay Yates
if you did could he have won at all with
Yates maybe not Ronnie maybe not flex
how about against Yates it's close
you're still saying it's close its close
not 100% 100% okay yeah so even with a
injured Yates he would have still an
injured weight and injured Yates yes he
would want he possibly win for now so
yeah the only reason I'm asking this
question is because you you know
sometimes when somebody obviously you
said you know how you feel about him as
an individual and as a body but it is
what it is it's so credit to you to be
able to say that if you had it I
couldn't think he saw somebody that at
the end of the day like Yates was
injured I thought I thought Nasser
beating
I thought Nasser beating there's
numerous guys that you know like flex
wheeler at a hundred percent on that
given day beat seemed like he you know
Dorian was very vulnerable that year
like he wasn't you know the Dorian of
you know that the years that he was so
dominant like he was a very vulnerable
athlete was a 98 97
okay so 97 he was a vulnerable he had
had the injury he wasn't in good shape
he had trouble controlling his
midsection like it was a train wreck for
him but he luckily pulled it off you
know and and it's probably still to this
day it's probably one of the most
controversial you know wins he's you
know he's got dominant body parts but
when you put you know you go pose for
pose
it's a tough it's tough to get to the
point where you can justify him winning
and don't get me wrong I'm a Dorian
Yates fan like I love everything about
him everything his work ethic his like I
love all of that you know but just on
that given year
he just wasn't his best so okay so now
let's talk about the other part so what
what made you so different than
everybody else's camp everybody has
access to certain things but was so
different with you but I think the
difference is so you're exactly right
everybody has access to the same thing
everybody does every okay so there isn't
like a mad
Juke potion out here that all of a
sudden this camp has like you know I
mean it doesn't matter like you've heard
all the stories about Kuwait like okay
you know yeah like oh [ __ ] like you know
that they had the anabolic chick and
everything but at the end of the day
they have access to exactly the same
things that everybody else has that what
a lot of people say though a lot I don't
say that our stuff is better than you
know Europe or Australia or you guys
actually I disagree like I think our
knowledge may be a little ahead I think
as far as like the science behind
everything but what they have access to
like as far as supplementation got it so
it's all the same so it's all the same
okay so what is the differentiator how
you piece it together how you put it on
the other so I think the difference is a
couple things one you have to be able to
motivate these guys and you have to be
able to click with them so that's why
like listen I didn't take on every
athlete that wanted to work with me
because there was a athletes that I knew
that we were just not going to click not
that I disliked them
not that I thought there was anything
bad about him I just knew like we
weren't going to be a good working
relationship I think that the key is
that the other key is I think most
nutritionists have one way of thinking
they have one way of doing everything so
keto diet is very you know very popular
right now there's a lot of trainers that
swear by a keto diet but it is virtually
impossible to think that every
bodybuilder that gets ready for a show
is going to be a hundred percent on a
keto diet it's impossible but most
trainers think that way they're they
only have one process that's it
you know if it's high carb or if it's
whatever it is that's the process that's
what they try to apply to everyone and
they try to force that bodybuilder to
with you know come within that guideline
I never thought that way ever I didn't
think that way on nutrition I didn't
think that way on training I felt like
everything had to be individualized I
felt like it had to be something one
that they could do so flex perfect
example I knew that he wasn't going to
be a guy that was going to be just you
know regimented and like this like
nitpicky guy that's going to be able to
eat X amount of this based on
personality
personality like and and a lot of that
was how I literally was able to get from
point A to point B so successfully
because with each person you have to
manage that and you know eventually you
end up with a guy like Ronnie Coleman
who is just a machine and you know I
remember the first time like we did
stuff together and he won the Olympia
and it's funny like the whole time I was
I was telling guys like man Ronnie
Coleman looks crazy and they're like
that third place best you know they're
they literally didn't think you know
until they saw him and then after the
thing and I've told the story before I
said no Ronnie just from my personal you
know and because I've dealt with all
these guys just for my personal use as
far as like what happened how many times
do you think you cheated on your diet
this was at the banquet and he looked
like me like I was nuts and he's like it
never even crossed my mind and I was
like and I knew at that point like oh
this is gonna be nuts like this guy is a
different human being but you had you
couldn't take that way of thinking was
wheeler like Chris Cormier like listen
like Chris Cormier was like I always
called it like the chaos factor because
if everything was going good for Chris
we were in big trouble like that was not
gonna work for Chris Chris had to be
kind of around this process of people
and things and stuff but there had to be
a controlled like point that we had to
get done like I knew that if he wasn't
busy like doing stuff he was gonna
literally be sitting at home playing
PlayStation eatin Captain Crunch like I
knew that's what he was going to do okay
so there had to be a process with that
that's not a bad thing on Chris it is
yeah okay most people could not figure
that out
they couldn't micromanage all of those
things or what however you want to put
that together they just couldn't do it
they forced them to go
Kito because this is my process and this
is how it works and this is how I do
everybody and this is how you have to do
it that's how I think I was so
successful like and I did the same thing
with training some people like look I
wasn't going to be able to have you know
flex wheeler trained the way Ronnie
Coleman did how
these guys you trained as well okay a
lot of them trained most like did a lot
of their stuff on their own but I would
like your likes like you know push them
in certain directions so if they were
doing a certain thing now a lot of
things like were flex had Charles glass
but again we would communicate because I
would want to know what Charles glass
was doing because what Charles glass was
doing it depended on what his diet was
doing so it you know like listen if they
all of a sudden are going high volume I
can't do certain things with his diet
because they're going heavy weight and
high volatile often were you talking to
trolls I didn't talk to Charles a lot
but I communicated more with flecks like
okay this is the direction we're going
this week and this is the things that
we're doing now me me and Charles you
know would communicate a little bit yeah
but it was mostly through through the
athlete stuff but the same with Chris
like I knew Chris you know when he built
the physique that he built he built it
off a hard work so even though like
Chris may not have been the best dieter
like you know as far as things and and
he would you know sometimes you know be
out late at night and partying and doing
the things that Chris did he still was a
hard worker in the gym he pushed a lot
of heavy weight that's how he built that
physique and so you know I had to make
sure that like look that's what we got
to do you know when it comes you know
contest I'm like we've got to you know
go those directions and stuff and I mean
that was part of the success like I
didn't ever I never tried to adapt them
to me I always tried to adapt to them
and apply and you don't think most
people do that I don't think anybody
does it okay so let me ask you this
other question how much of it is
genetics how much of it is training how
much of it is diet how much of it is
drugs so it's the biggest issue is food
so I'm telling everyone that's number
one so food is without a doubt number
one and when you say food what do you
mean by I mean being consistent and that
doesn't mean that doesn't mean offseason
or contest that's across the board so if
you are in the offseason and you're not
consistent with food if you're not
continuously pushing food and it's
probably every it's probably the
majority of athletes downfall because
they get to offseason and they're like
it's offseason like I don't I don't have
to eat six meals a day I don't have to
quite just if I don't feel like
I'll just skip a meal and I'll go grab
some fast food and these things it's
probably the biggest downfall it's hard
to eat six seven eight meals a day with
high calories so that your body is
literally in a calorie surplus all the
time every single day it's hard to do
it's probably how I end up weaning out
more athletes and not because they'll be
like I can heat all day I'll never have
a problem and five days later like
there's no way I can eat all this food
it's just tough
most people don't realize it that's
first though not a doubt
hard work and training is second so
second without a doubt is training so
you have to be able to push yourself you
have to be able to put in work and again
consistency you have to be able to
figure out what works for you you have
to be able to go in every single day and
push beyond really what the body is
capable of push push push mentally third
is probably drugs is it it would be
ludicrous to say that it's not part of
it because at the highest level it is
part of it but it's definitely after
food and training and then after that is
probably genetics is going to fall in
between probably training and drugs
actually so you don't think genetics is
more important in food no you really
know I don't can I ask you a question on
that challenge yeah so here's a question
before you competed Yeah right okay when
you competed you you know this stuff so
you could have applied it for yourself
to go to the top right absolutely and
I'm and the only reason I'm asking this
is because some guys you know like I'm
six four and a half right
the chances of me going out there the
tallest guy that ever wanted you know
what it's Arnold so right don't you
think like there's a sweet spot of
genetics too cuz you know do you look at
some of them without a doubt you without
a doubt like with me like talking to win
about to compete yes yeah to win for
sure
now that axis first with it's definitely
at the top of the of the game because
when you because when you're talking
tiny tiny percentages like you're
talking like because when you look at
that you know you can look at the top
group right now list so the top three at
the Olympia was
and you you had bow and AK and you had a
hottie okay so all three of those guys
are phenomenal phenomenal bodybuilders
but in reality none of them have the
genetics of Phil Heath none of them
which is why if Phil Heath is in that
group he is a superior athlete without a
doubt but when you look at all three of
those they all three have phenomenal
genetics so there's no way you can say
like Brandon Currie has bad genetics
William Bowen AK has bad genetics they
all have at the top top of the genetic
field but there is always going to be
that outlying guy that is a Phil Heath
and a flex wheeler that is just
god-given that there's no hard work that
there's no that there is or that there
isn't well there's nothing that can
match that okay I got so listen there's
like flex wheeler Kia I don't care how
hard you work I don't care how many
things you take I don't care who you
have working we're not gonna look like
because you're never gonna look like
flex wheeler yeah ever yeah ever now
flex wheeler was beat by hard work there
was guys that out worked him you know
but that wasn't because of you know they
were better than flex that was just
because flex let him let them getting
you know you mind educating our audience
on anabolic steroids
is that okay if we do that let's talk
about that okay so we've had people that
have been on and they've talked about
you know Dorian will talk openly he
doesn't really I mean Dorian literally
could care less what do you talk about
he'll talk about psychedelics he'll talk
about just a whole different guy when he
talks about it but for me you know when
it comes up to this topic I think most
people are uneducated on it most people
don't know first thing they hear about
it they're automatically there's a red
flag and and there's a misunderstanding
on it so when it comes onto steroids
when it comes onto steroids
how do you view anabolic steroids
yourself and then we'll go out topics of
what each one is and why some people use
right
I think the steroids is one of the
things that get well especially now okay
now it gets a bad rap because of all the
social media so the stuff that's out
there on social media is crazy and I
think that there is so much bad
information there's so much like
negative put toward it because of all
the craziness that goes with it right
but if you look at every sport I mean
you you know the Olympics is coming up
and we're going to see athlete after
athlete after athlete failed drug test
there's no doubt and it's beneficial
across the board obviously where people
wouldn't use it now you know we're not
talking about swimmers dying we're not
talking about this because I think they
use it in a term just to benefit just to
enhance just to do those things and it's
been around for a year so if you even if
you look at the backstory you know
Russia created testosterone literally
and basically for the Olympics I mean it
was literally created for the Olympics
that's what it was then our scientist
was like hey listen Russia has
testosterone what we need something now
but we need something easier and faster
so they created Dianabol so now our
people had Dianabol and the original
Dianabol was very fast it was an oral
pill and you know the athletes obviously
used it and then all of a sudden it was
banned obviously but it was a writ
that's I mean the whole basis if you
look back that far
it was literally created from the
Olympics like that's literally what it
was research for and created so I think
that when you look at it bodybuilding is
going to get a bad rap because look
we're you know you look at a swimmer a
swimmer is in 300 pounds right there is
some baseball players and football
players but they don't look like
bodybuilders but when you're talking
about a muscle enhancing drug and the
sport is muscle bodybuilding is for sure
going to get the biggest rap on it
because they're gonna be like these guys
are abusing it they're not just taking
it to enhance their they're abusing it
and in reality they're probably just
some people that are doing that but I
believe that the majority of people that
take it don't be
I think that the majority of the people
that are on the pro level that are
literally at you know at the highest
level of this sport are all pretty damn
close I don't think they're doing
anything more or less I think they're
all pretty damn close aware of where
they're at and really damn close a word
there right yeah and I mean and that
doesn't mean and that's not pointing the
finger at whoever they're working with
they could be in Kuwait they could be
training with somebody over here they
could be wherever I believe that nobody
is that far outside the thing I may be
wrong on that but that's the way I feel
I mean I hear I hear different things
but again I I'm just trying to kind of
get educated on this with you here and
by the way for full disclosure you are
not a doctor I am absolutely something
you've been around and you brethren
we've experienced it so okay so why
would somebody use these two drugs
obviously you got clenbuterol up here
and you know what the top one is lasix
Oakland puter all is basically a drug
use for conditioning so most people use
that to get in shape so it's used it has
actually a relatively long half-life so
most people don't use it for extended
periods of time they will use it for a
little bit of time I believe the
half-life is 36 hours or something which
is in you know that type of thing that's
actually relatively long so they'll use
it a couple days and usually go off on
for a couple days but it's basically to
burn fat now lasix is a different one
that's a loop diuretic and it's not used
obviously for contest prep it's used at
the end for basically finishing the look
on stage it's probably in my opinion one
of the least used drugs in the sport
because most people don't realize that
how dangerous the product is because the
drug was actually named lay six because
it's actually a six hour diuretic but if
you look at it and you read it the
half-life is very short on it so most
people who have gotten in trouble back
in when you seen guys actually got in
trouble with it was from this drug they
got in trouble with it because they
would take it and two hours later like
they still
holding water so they would take a
little more of it and two hours later
they were still holding a little water
so they would take a little more of it
now they have literally 12 hours
basically or more of lasix pulling
pulling them down pulling them down
pulling them down and so because of that
I believe most people have went away
from lasix just for the simple fact that
it's it's relatively dangerous and it's
relatively hard to predict on what it's
going to do it's not fast enough to use
and so because of that which is a good
thing I don't think people are using it
that much people are now using I don't
think so now Columbia law the question
that I got for you is a lot of these
things are not necessarily for
bodybuilding bodybuilders use a Columbia
doll is an asthma patient so absolutely
yeah they use it daddy I mean and they
also use it there's a product called
ventolin which is also a clenbuterol
which is a gel pump that they actually
literally pump into cattle feed to to
like create bigger leaner cows so this
is used for what bodybuilders use or
know what's they used it I mean lasix
has been around for years like I said
it's a loop diuretic I don't think it's
being used very much anymore
because I think the guys that that
literally got in trouble with diuretics
I think they got in trouble with it from
using lasix because they didn't
understand the diuretic itself what's
the side effect of clam you know any
realistically no side effects I mean
there is obviously some side effects but
very very safe at low dose is that is
that similar to would you put the side
effects of Anna fed rein compared to
like computer all in the old like
ephedrine like the e back in the days
all that stuff yes very very similar
very similar that's the same drug
obviously I know something absolutely ok
so let's go through these now these are
actually some of the famous ones that
you see and hear about all the time what
are they used for and what are the side
effects and benefits of each okay so
testosterone obviously everybody knows
that's you sipping a chiffonade they're
sipping eight and Nant eight these are
slow-acting esters so basically when
you're talking testosteron you're
talking about building up a baseline now
bodybuilder what they're looking at
doing obviously is creating a stable
base
so again most people take testosterone
because they don't understand it so they
just keep taking take and take and take
and take it you have to realize how it
comes in and out of the system so
realistically the key is basically just
hitting a baseline and keeping it there
because it's going to be based off of
the level of testosterone within your
body this is out in about 72 hours so
from the time you take it to the time
it's out it's going to start decreasing
in about 72 hours so it literally it
could be taken realistically only twice
a week and maintain a stable
testosterone level which is why most
people that are on like their you know
like prohormone like the you know yes
yes and and stuff like that when they
reach 50 and those types of things
will go to a slow-acting testosterone
like sipping aid and Anantha and at a
very low dose you know is very very safe
and actually probably not only safe but
better for you because as the natural
males testosterone drops the body tight
actually tries to counter that and
literally then everything else starts to
go out of balance but as long as your
natural testosterone level stays in line
where it normally is especially on a
male that you just function better at
that point so it's probably safer to
have a normal testosterone level normal
level perfect thousand and most athletes
that have been an athlete all their life
functions somewhere like at that
thousand range now a non-athlete just
somebody that's going in there you know
whose level probably test it out at 200
will probably feel amazing at 700 at 700
yeah when you say amazing what do you
mean by me like just revitalize like you
know just feel like you know normal
again normal normal okay how about the
rest trim alone acetate so that's a
fast-acting drug most people take that I
say it's actually kind of made of
surgeons because most people took that
pre-contest it was something that added
hardness to the muscle but it is
something that it's probably right now
the most abuse drug in the sport this is
that right there yes because of what it
does so it makes you strong it makes you
aggressive it
it's the one drug that's probably the
single most abused drug in the sport it
crossed the board like I don't care what
sport it is it could be powerlifting
it's probably across the board across
the so you're saying professional
athletes are using this across the wheel
without a doubt and it's fast acting so
it's in and out of the system relatively
quick so you can use it use a
water-based or oil but it's oil base
okay yeah and that's that is very fast
in and out of the system so but it's
also now there's other ones though but
this is acetate so that's a faster
acting one but it's like I said like it
was originally there was a drug called
FINA ject which is back in the day which
is very similar to it but this product
is was you know used you know back in
the day when people were doing things
like normal it was used you know last
eight weeks and now it's probably used
almost all year I guarantee of those
guys that use it all year guarantee what
what are the side effects of this that
would be anything like blood pressure is
gonna be a major issue with trend that's
gonna be you're gonna run and deliver in
kidney issues with that like that's
gonna be a harsh drug could actually it
could do it I mean most steroids aren't
going to like kill you like like an
opiate would kill you but there's no
doubt that long-term effect of that
could be a way of your kidney liver
stomach it could eat away everything
like it could destroy your body I had a
high dose and that's the problem with
that like that drug is probably more
abuse than any other drug on this in in
the sport and it's it's abused at high
levels because high what do you mean by
high like I mean well for instance I
would say that people probably so 75
milligrams is what that is I would say
they took that three times a week back
in the day so back in the 80s or 90s
back in the 90s that would be you know
what 225 I would say they're doing that
every day now 225 a day a day possible
you mean the guys on stage I would say
and actually there's the thing that's
probably more amateurs than pros so the
amateurs are probably abusing all of
this stuff way beyond what the pro
because again the pros have phenomenal
genetics they have people helping them
like I can tell you like I don't care
how many people like you can throw every
nutritionist under you know under the
bus there isn't anybody gonna like
prescribe this like recommend this for
you know high dosages year-round like
nobody but there are some like gym guys
out there that will be because when you
take that you feel phenomenal so the
more of that [ __ ] you take the more you
feel phenomenal you start getting strong
next thing you know you're benching 500
pounds you you know you've gained 30
pounds your muscle looks hard and you're
like holy [ __ ] if 200 as good as this
just think what a thousand is on this
and that's the problem with a lot of
time people think how about how about
the master own yeah it's like master on
phenol propionate is something that's
taken in last five weeks of their show
so it's a hardening drug mainly to add
basically hardness to the skin
it's literally taken for no more than
five weeks no more than five we know how
different is that them Primo ball it's a
similar drug than Prima bone there's two
different kinds of premium ball to so it
would be the effect of it would be very
similar to like the old parabola or
prima ball and acetate prima ball and
depo is a slower acting drug which some
people do take in pre-contest but most
people use that I don't even know if
they it's even made anymore but it's
it's a little bit different
how about Dec I mean you everybody for
somebody that doesn't know about stores
they're for today it's like like the
original right it's like what Arnold and
the boys used it's probably it's it's
something that I'd actually don't like
I'm not big on a lot of people like it
because they think it helps their joints
things that makes her joints fill I
think the side effects of that is it's
not like harsh side effects but it's a
very slow acting it literally just shuts
the body down like your sex drive
literally drops to nothing once you're
off yeah what you're on it now you're
honest yes you got to take so many
different things just to keep your body
balance back out like deck it to me is
like one of the worst things it's a safe
drug as far as like side effects to the
body but the way you feel on it like
most people that's ever taken it
will tell you instantly like I hate the
way I feel on it
I hate the way I feel absolutely yeah
and I and I think because of that and
that and here we come back to this so
back in the day that's what they would
use they would take a little bit of
testosterone a little bit of Dec and if
you talk to the old guys they'll tell ya
right they'll tell you even back in
Arnold today that's what we took great
now like they don't go to that like
they're like listen I feel like [ __ ] on
that but I can take trend and feel crazy
I'll stick with the trend but it's it's
a much harsher harsher on your body and
we're being pretty open here Anke poised
is actually very similar to like decade
so it's almost there different drugs but
the makeup the the way they respond in
the body almost identical I like that
one though because it doesn't have a lot
of the like you know sex side effects
and type of thing like decreased you
know that how would stories decrease sex
you know it will you be surprised so it
just literally lowers your libido it
there's so many effects that it has like
on it but the acupoints doesn't so
people will have a tendency to stay away
from decking building EQ but it's also a
slower acting drug so deck is really
slower acting and most people don't use
deca because it can be detected for so
long so that's why they stay away from
here we go so this the next topic aghgh
an insulin insulin yep so this is where
the sport changed obviously from like a
certain point nineteen nineties or and
stuff yeah and so the girl one one had
always been around and I think people
were using it but what they didn't
realize is how the effect of the two
worked together simultaneously and
basically the the insulin and and the
insulin kind of had like when it first
came out I think they that people
overdid it
you know honestly I do and I think like
you know me and even a couple other you
know people were kind of the first ones
that was like listen if you take the
insulin every single day it stops
working like literally and you know
there was people I was like listen you
know how long have you taken that and
they'd be like now I've you know I've
been doing it now for three months and
I'm like how much are you taking they're
like 15 units a day I'm like I'll tell
you what take the 15 units and don't eat
don't eat any carbs when I call
I'll crash and I'm like I'm telling you
you won't you won't crash and they were
calling back in their black hole [ __ ]
like I took the 15 units I didn't crash
I'm like exactly because your body now
is used to it like your body is
literally limiting what the natural
production is and so I think a lot of
people the nutritionists like that knew
what they were doing literally kind of
curtailed that a little bit and took a
lot of the people away now I say that
I've seen like some like really crazy
like resurgence of insulin over the last
like six months so but up until this
point it has been very very limited it
was used very like once or twice a week
it was used maybe a couple times after
training you know a week or something
like that just to make sure that
everything was completely loaded
completely you know like the body was
functioning at a hundred percent but
they weren't like abusing it trying to
force glycogen non-stop basically trying
to upload everything they weren't but
now there has been a little bit of an
like like the protocols that are out
there that seem to be floating around
are bad right now they're like really
bad what's the biggest difference
between the side effects of HGH and
insulin versus steroids anabolic
the totally to separate you know things
I mean obviously steroids are all based
really based off of testosterone and
those types of things where growth
hormone is is basically your based off
your growth hormone levels and and
insulin is obviously you know based off
of insulin levels so they all have a
different functioning purpose within the
body now obviously all three together
are a very powerful combination
combination and and realistically maybe
one of the most powerful ones is insulin
as when you're looking at you know the
hormone mega it could be the most
powerful hormone within the body but it
doesn't do legitimately what you think
it's going to do and I think a lot of
people when they first were was
introduced to it they thought like holy
[ __ ] I'm gonna do all these things and
I'm gonna look like ASSA relson body or
I'm gonna look like and just know it's
not gonna happen like they can take
insulin all day
most most of the people that I see that
take high doses of insulin just get fat
just get fast please get fat yeah you
hear about these your thoughts on this
so I hate this stuff like all of the
synthol and this stuff there are some
people I think most people hate it like
I can tell you it's the one thing that I
hate within the sport I can honestly say
like I've never ever like you know like
encouraged an athlete of mine to take it
I've had two athletes of mine use it and
it was literally kind of against my you
know that I don't like it I think that
it is one of those things that we
literally have no idea what it is and
everybody is like you know it's you know
you put it in the muscle it stays from
the muscle there's no chance it could
stay in the muscle I don't care how much
of it you pump into the muscle there's
no chance it has to end up somewhere and
those places have to be brain lung heart
so a percentage of that has to come out
of the muscle it the way it basically
like hardens if it doesn't clear out of
the system it's going to end up there
it's going to end up almost like
cholesterol like so if you've seen an
artery that is filled with cholesterol
my thinking is how is this not binding
to it how is this not binding to
cholesterol and a lot of people think
I'm nuts
you know I know Dave Palumbo is a big
very you know like he's very proactive
on this and and but he sells it also too
and it's it's not illegal in any way
shape or form but I'm just one of these
guys that thinks that it is not a
positive first we'll just kill you I
think a hundred percent can kill you is
there is there stories of that happening
or no you know I mean the world of body
they're they're not necessarily there's
a lot of stories where people have had
trouble with it I know of a guy that
literally had open-heart surgery from
Chicago that took it and when they
opened him up he they literally had that
[ __ ] everywhere like it was everywhere
so they're you know I see so pop are
people like is it is it two together
without doing the work I mean even some
of your guys that did it they're
well-known bodybuilders there's so much
sure there's a lot of yeah and that's
the thing I mean I think a lot of
people have done it I think a lot of
well-known people have done it mr.
Olympius says they frown upon it but
they know some people are using it on
disqualifier do anything with this thing
I think that the key is there has been
you know like there has been some guys
that have done it that you either
couldn't tell or at least it looked
really well they did it really really
well
I think those are far a few between okay
I think that there's very few guys they
can do and last but not least this is
simple this is obviously know what this
is so those are all like estrogen
blockers those are probably two of the
most common ones there's another one
that probably everybody uses which is
aromasin which is another one but it's
very expensive these are obviously used
because as you take more and more
testosterone your estrogen level will
then start to crank up obviously you
need a certain balance of estrogen we do
need a certain you do so you don't want
to limit all of your estrogen within the
body but you want to keep it at under
control
so what ends up happening is the higher
estrogen levels you end up with
everybody sort of like the gyno and
those types of things those are the same
family right Nova Dex is the same in the
same family and Nova Dex is tricky
because Nova Dex you if you take that
for an extended period of time that will
actually decrease your estrogen but it
will also decrease your growth on one
level so you have to kind of counter
some of those things and to most people
that take estrogen blockers will take
those for short periods of time and Nova
Dex literally nobody takes it at least
to my knowledge for any longer than five
weeks nobody takes it for longer than
five we know okay and is that off coming
off a cycle like you're you're getting
off of it it depends like they can use
it coming off a cycle but I think a lot
of people will use it like mid cycle or
you know whatever even in the offseason
just to control estrogen levels because
obviously you know you don't want higher
estrogen levels could create a lot of
serious issues with them within the body
the gyno is like the extreme but just
even like having a high level of
estrogen like you can tell like the way
the skin looks like yellow or yeah well
and just even like how much water you
hole I see what your stuff - so so let
me ask you that so you a somebody who
has no desire to compete they're not
going to be a bodybuilder
they're just a 29 year old guys watching
this saying you know what I want to go
use stuff there's different
conversations here about the usage of
steroids right and then there is when
you said the guy about 45 55 you know he
goes to the Donatello 180 or 121 I do
doctor says you may consider trt right
you know something like that
what is your counsel you give to
somebody that has zero plans of being a
professional athlete using under 50
versus the person about 50 so my here's
my thinking so I tell everybody like
obviously the choice is yours like
you're gonna have to make the Detroit
you know this is sure but if you have
zero interest zero interest in competing
I would think long and hard before using
anything so go to touch it now because
my thinking is why are you gonna take it
like like now when you get into that
forty range and your level is literally
coming down without a doubt like I think
that you're crazy not to take it because
I think that the benefit literally
outweighs the risk like with a hundred
percent like a hundred percent but the
guy that's wanting to just literally
walk around and look like a freakin a
t-shirt for no other reason than looking
like a freak there's a lot of stuff
that's over-the-counter that can
literally benefit you such as I mean
there's a lot of pro hormones and we
don't even have like great Pro hormones
anymore because most of them are illegal
but there's still like a lot of you know
I mean like there's some stuff that
pushes the envelope a little bit that
would that would benefit you legally
legally so yeah are you talking like
back in the days one now back in the day
the preneurcast and all the tests and
all of that stuff like would be great
you know and and now there's still a few
I know high tech has a few I know
Blackstone has a few and they're
legitimate like products that literally
work and like to me like if you're not
planning on competing if you don't have
a goal at the end like if there's not a
reason like why are you doing it like it
makes my number one that's my number one
if you're not trying to compete if
you're not trying to you know go out
there and do something with it there's
no reason to do there's plenty of
supplements to be able to train with it
but I like what Brandon curry says first
get the training
get the diet and then consider that
we're talking about this because of the
the reason why you are here after the
response we got was John and would get
her a bit deeper in this topic so now
let's go to the last part of what he
said uh in the video where he says you
know this person's life you know that
person is this person right so obviously
these are some names sure we'll go
through them together you obviously know
who these are monster
you know else embodies or in mathura so
and then we have some other guys you
will get to hear in a minute so you know
when you look at this what was the cause
of death with what was this control by
it or we don't know so with monterossa
like one of my best friends was best
friends with him so one of my best
friends Mel Chauncey was very very good
friends with it I've heard nothing but
good things about it
moderato yeah one of the greatest guys
on this whatever like phenomenal
personality like on just a phenomenal
guy phenomenal guy realistically I
believe that he was like hereditary like
I think that his father died at a
relatively young age of heart issues
like Ken can you say like did did the
things that he did escalated possibly
like possibly but I mean I don't think
that there was anything like he wasn't
like terminal because of bodybuilding I
think that there's no doubt like some of
the choices he made without a doubt
could have you know changed the the
process but I think that I think he died
of cardiac arrest if I'm not mistaken
and I think it was a hereditary issue
else somebody because Shawn put that on
put that one on there right so here's
the thing with with Naser so naasson was
probably one of my best friends within
the industry so he me and him were
together a lot I talked to him probably
more than any other bodybuilder ever
that I'd worked with so me and NASA were
very very close my relationship was not
with NASA was very unique because most
of my guys I was a hundred percent in
control of a hundred percent in control
but Nasser was a little bit different so
if anybody the new Nasser he was a very
very intelligent man spoke seven
different languages like he was a very
smart human being
and so my role with him was literally
more advisory maybe I guess you'd say or
friend like you know whatever and so you
know literally the shows that I would
work with him I worked with him for yet
9700 Olympia 98 Olympia 99 Arnold okay
so those were the main shows that I
worked with him and and I didn't
literally take over all of his stuff
until the last week so I would control
definitely alright his like final prep
stuff but the rest of the stuff was you
know at this point you know by the time
he got there like he was big like he was
like I didn't need to be like hey listen
this is the way you need to train or
this is what you need to do he would you
know send me pictures and be like how
close am i and I'm like dude you're
behind like we need to we need to drop
the hammer like we need to crank things
up like that was where the things were
he would ask me like hey I'm getting I'm
thinking about adding this in I'd be
like yeah that's probably a good idea or
no that's that you don't need that yet
or those types of things but there was
never like this is what you do right
here this is what you followed that it
ended up now the thing with Nasser is
like this is the thing that's
interesting about Nasser so again like
he literally puts that one on me right
so but literally I didn't train him
after 99 and he died 14 years later like
I'm not really sure how like okay I'm
not even sure how you even go down that
road like it's so idiotic like I mean
like he could have lived 20 more years
and then you're like yeah that was still
there like yeah monster obviously you
hadn't you never did it monster but it's
interesting I talked to months or the
year he died and so he he was a very
unique individual he was a super nice
guy I didn't speak really good English
so it was like tough - it was tough to
communicate with him and we were you
know we were talking about some stuff
and then we were talking about a certain
thing that he was using and then he
mentioned another it was a cortisol
blocker that he was talking about and
and then he mentioned another cortisol
blocker it was it was a weird was a
weirdest conversation I'll never forget
it
like I said you realize those are the
same thing and he's like now they're
different and I'm like no I said this is
the American version this is a European
version and now he was double-dip yeah
and so he was double dipping on those
now those are notorious for eating up
like your stuff they're really hard on
the stomach like even at a moderate to
low dose and and he was doing a
humungous dose of now I'm not saying
that's what had anything to do with it
but the conversation that I had was very
like so weird because I remember going
up to Kim and being like these guys
don't even know what they're doing like
they were talking about Disney like the
same thing like what the hell is going
on and then literally we get home from
the Arnold that year and there and then
he had died on the plane early at least
coming you know over there and he was
like an anatomy chart laughter your call
well no I just literally talked to him
and it was a very brief letter like it
was at the show we were talking about
stuff and he has no sense dumb and he
was actually commenting on Kim's
physiques like he was like he was like
being like I've never seen a you know a
female's quads that lean that are done
we're like you got to accumulate look at
your quad okay
let's let's just go - lets go to Dallas
Dallas ky here so obviously that's the
controversial one that about whatever
sure so for sure there's a there's a
dialogue between Dallas and Sean when
they go backstage you know that whole
thing I've been thrown aside and what's
your relationship with Dallas because
that's the biggest one he puts on the
biggest one right so here's the thing
with Dallas so I worked with Dallas for
three months that was it I only worked
with him for one show I met with him and
November at Nationals and I prepped him
for the Arnold I became very close with
Dallas during that time and you know
Dallas was one of these guys that was
just a likable like there's no way you
couldn't like Dallas like he was
probably one of the most genuine nicest
people I had ever met in my life
he was super honest about everything
like there were so many things that
would like so I never literally
second-guessed him about anything
because the things he told me like I
would have like never dreamed that he
would have told me honestly like you
know he told me you know things just
from way back way back and there was you
know the thing that I
probably one of the toughest things for
me it was like when I when I think back
through all this stuff like there were
signs right from the get-go like when we
first literally very first week of the
diet so we started we literally kind of
started like the beginning of December
and so we had talked at Nationals which
is the middle of November and then we
started in December so I only literally
worked with him for three months he
worked with another guy for two years
before that and another guy before that
and then the guy two years before me he
ended up working with when he died but
the very first week like he calls me is
like listen I'm throwing up and I'm like
like oh that's not I said are you feel
okay he's like yeah he goes you know I
do that a lot because I've done it all
my life I got like a weird stomach but
he's like I didn't know whether I should
like replaced a meal or not and so I'm
thinking like wait a minute like what do
you mean he did that your whole life and
he's like well I thrown up my whole life
I got a weird stomach like I literally
throw up like I threw up before every
football game I've thrown up like before
every contact like every contest diet
I've ever had I threw up so I'm like I
said listen like don't be let's just see
how this plays out because you may be
sick you may have the stomach flu or
something so the week goes on and he
seems fine and then Thursday throws up
again so I'm like okay listen this thing
normally you don't just throw up you're
like literally 25 years old or something
I'm like go to the like urgent care like
I want you to go to Urgent Care like
you're throwing up now this is a week
two weeks into your relationship ninety
days this is a week into the
relationship right and so he comes back
and he's like yeah they think that I may
have bronchitis and the drainages like
coming you know drown and Smits make me
throw up
and I'm like well how do you feel any
goes I feel great but he goes listen I
get bronchitis all the time because I've
had pneumonia ten times in my life and
I'm like well what I go you've had
pneumonia ten times in your life he's
like yeah he goes like oh I literally
like always get it and he kind of blamed
it like like and he was very hoping
about this so I have no problem talking
but he's like yeah smoke weeds from the
time I was 12 years old he goes I
probably smoke more weed than anybody
you know that kind of coughing I have
drainage and that's kind of what it kind
of leads to and I'm like okay I mean it
sounded pneumonia from weed no but if he
was saying he gets pneumonia and I was
trying to
the coffee so the coughing the drainage
Ani is like you know he's like I
stricted breathing and then he ends up
was like bronchitis and pneumonia and so
I'm kind of thinking like yeah you know
I get the coughing like the pneumonia
thing sounds a little weird like I don't
know let's see how you feel I said you
why don't you rest for a couple days
let's see how you feel
weekend goes by feels fine a couple
weeks ago buys back throwing up again
and I'm like dude this is not normal
like you shouldn't be throwing up and
he's like Chad I'm telling you I throw
up all the time like I literally that
I've done it my entire life and that's
the one thing thinking back like I'm
like you know like where was that hit
like how in the hell like where was that
head you know and so we go through the
process like through the whole process I
can tell like something's off like his
body is not really responding like I
thought it would it didn't you know and
then and like I don't know if people
even believe this but like based off of
what he had been doing we literally did
half of that what he had been doing so a
lot of this stuff so he's saying you're
doing half of what he was doing half of
what he was doing so my thinking was
like holy [ __ ] like maybe like his
body's not responding well like maybe he
it's not because we pulled back so far
right but then all of a sudden his body
kind of started to come around and
everything started to look halfway
decent so we just you know and then he
actually kind of started feeling better
everything kind of seems like right on
target we go and we're literally
planning on going into Pittsburgh to
meet with Mannion let him look am take
look am posing just critique posing all
these little things we're sitting there
and he starts throwing up again like
with the stuff and so I'm like okay it's
like dude like how like this is not
normal you shouldn't be vomiting all the
time and he's like Jedi listen like this
is just my life like this is what I do
like I vomit I have a weak stomach like
I this goes all the way back to football
like he goes all the way back to
football and so I'm like okay so we go
through the process through this whole
process I can tell like
somes clearly off his body didn't
respond well like nothing's really
responded well so and so we start
talking we start talking about like just
personal things like you know and so he
had moved away from his hometown he went
to Boca to be part of the company that
he was with and everything and so we
literally and this was after the Arnold
so he ends up second you know he goes to
New Zealand which I literally didn't
even want him to go to because I thought
he was sick in at the Arnold like he was
like Hocking up [ __ ] like I literally
said listen don't go but he had already
like signed contracts like he was
already committed he's like I have to go
I have already signed a contract and I'm
like listen just go to the doctor and
you know get it he's like no I'm gonna
go so we so we go there and then and
then of course he's super sick in
Australia almost passes out on stage
like we literally like literally two
hours before that we were literally
talking on the phone and I'm like don't
do the show like I don't want you to do
the show and he's like I'm gonna take a
nap and we'll see how I feel two hours
later he calls back man I feel
phenomenal I feel great you know and I'm
like are you sure anything I feel
phenomenal like I just needed a nap I
think it was a flight wore me out then
of course it goes onstage the damn
theater passes out so then he you know
it comes back home and so through this
whole process I'm like listen
something's off like I think that you're
unhappy like listen I don't think that I
think you left your home I think you
moved to Boca you don't know people
there you're in a stay in an apartment
by yourself like like you're doing all
this stuff that's like not making you
happy like it's not making you happy I'm
like you need to get out of there get
completely out of there
go back home and at the time he didn't
have a good relationship with his family
but he was trying to mend that and I go
go back home like you know create this
bond with your family that you're trying
to do do do all of these types of things
and I said I said I said we don't even
need to work together I said go back
home and his coach was in his hometown I
go go back with him I said because I
think that friendship stabilized you
like I think it stabilized you I think
you were happier within that environment
I think a lot of your friends and gym
people were there and he was like you
know like that's I think that's what I'm
gonna do and so that's where we kind of
left things like we kind of left things
many looking back on that now I'm like
was that the right decision like was
like was me just kind of saying go back
home like go into that thing because it
was literally right after that that they
started posting up pictures and I could
tell instantly something was wrong
like instantly and then I became like in
this like tug of war with myself like
okay do I call up him and say dude what
the hell are you guys doing like
something looks off here and then like a
my budding in on this because I'm not
working him anymore I'm not the coach
and they're like it's kind of an under
you know like written rule like you
don't interfere with other people's
stuff but I felt like man something's
off like I knew it and then the last
picture he posted I'll never forget this
Dan Salomon called me and he's like have
you seen the picture of Dallas and I'm
like I'm like I have I said he doesn't
look good and he literally looks like
he's getting ready to drop dead
I said and and Dan Solomon says I dude I
just saw him and he looks like he's
walking death and I said that's what he
looks like in the picture I said he's
gray I said his skin looks funky like
he's in a hospital he said no no no he
just they're just posting up progress
pictures online and and I'm like I said
he doesn't look good like he just looked
unhealthy and two days later he died
like and that's the story like you know
I didn't you know like I wasn't training
him during the time I trained him for
three months I didn't train him for the
next four months or whatever from the
time he died I have no idea what they
did I have no idea what he was doing so
not fortunate story because he uh you
know you again and stories like this you
get a lot of different versions of it on
what happens but he was a guy that was
alike guy he was coming at the most like
together that's what's then Ike I'm
telling you like he was if not the most
liked guy like I mean I'm telling you
like you were never gonna find anybody
that had anything negative to say it let
me ask you two about there's a there's
an article online that says the supposed
Alice McCarver anabolics on technical
right right and all of this stuff here
that it's got you know I mean the list
is it's not I'll tell you first of all
that's not I can tell you I've already
seen it I it was sent to me I can tell
you exactly what it is if you want me to
tell you yeah yeah absolutely this is
not his cycle this is a drug list that
him and his coach ordered that's the
list they ordered that's it that's a
drug list that's a rug order list but
that's not you this has nothing to do
okay so I can tell you that was this is
pre you or both this is after me I
believe this is either pre me or after
me but this has nothing to do with me
and Dallas at all like oh that's
sometimes that's a lot ridiculous now
but this supposedly what I was told is a
shopping list for him and one other
person that's what I was told and I was
told that from the literally the person
they ordered it problem how it's a
legitimate like like it's a legitimate
guy that told me that so it's a
legitimate guy guy told you but this has
got this part has nothing to do with you
ordering with them that's saying
anything to do okay like this literally
I like I can tell you by like there's so
much stuff on this because I believe
this is the one because I've seen too
this is the one with EPO on it yeah and
it's it's weird because that drug right
there I can promise you like he didn't
use with me but he asked me about that
drug and it's weird because I didn't
even think anything about it but we were
at the Harned
and he said listen we're just
bullshitting and he goes listen he goes
I've heard people use EPO and I'm like
yeah I go listen I know of maybe three
people that could have benefited or it
has benefited from EPO I said very few
people because it's a drug that
literally like endurance people use
right it doesn't really play a factor
with bodybuilders there are some very
rare rare instances that possibly and
he's like and then he asked me this
question I'll never forget this and and
this was before I ever
this list he asked me how long do they
stay on that and I'm like five weeks max
and he's like really he goes have you
ever heard of anybody staying on longer
than that and I'm like yes cyclists like
cyclists he goes bodybuilders and I'm
like no and he goes so nobody like six
months a year and I'm like that would be
I go do that he's asking he's asking me
that question and I said no I said that
would be friggin idiotic like I said get
a sense that he asked you because he had
done for six months or you don't have
any idea I didn't have any idea what he
was asking me but then when I saw this
then I saw the EPO on it and that's when
I was like holy [ __ ] like what was he
asking about like and then it was and
then I had already seen this list and it
wasn't until after the list that
somebody told me like well you know what
that list is that's a that's an order
list you know and if you know anybody
involved with this list there's a couple
things on the list at points right - the
list is who it came from
yes okay and your world would know who
that is my world would a hundred percent
no that is a 100 percent no that has
nothing to do with me okay so so let me
let me ask you this the reason why I'm
going to in this direction is the
following is I'm a fan of the sport at
this point of the game you know I'm a
fan fan support I showed you a picture
earlier what I look like when I was 20
years old I wanted was amazing I mean I
was crazy
yeah I wanted to go in the world in the
direction of being a body but then a one
minute I'm like no I'm leaving it so
with the current state of where mr.
Olympia is with no Joe Weider
there's not a wieder right there's not
somebody that's selling it pitching it's
you know from the time and with the
current social media conditions where
someone like this wouldn't be around
1994 so I'm not gonna write an article
like this and say hey look what you
someone's not gonna be online saying hey
Chad hey great ok that's not the world
we're in today not today 25 years ago
right so today where everybody is quick
to jump and say I can't believe what
happened there what do you foresee
taking place with the future of mr.
Olympia today and bodybuilding and what
do you think needs to happen for it to
become mainstream rather than a niche
small communities
fort of don't bring too much attention a
little bit is good we can make money but
let's not bring a lot of attention to it
I think the direction that we're headed
right now is positive
like literally positive and there's a
couple things like the the direction
that the Olympia went last year now
people are gonna rip the [ __ ] out of the
Olympia last year because there wasn't a
like a defending champ there wasn't big
names in it and so you know I honestly
feel sorry for Brandon curry a little
bit because you know he was in a no-win
situation like him Bowen AK Hadi like
listen any three of those guys could
have won and they all three are gonna go
through what kind of Brandon is going
through a little bit right now and
they're all gonna be like well of course
he won because he didn't beat anyone
there was nobody in it bow neck wins he
goes through the same thing like they
all do it but at the end of the day
Brandon Currie earned the right to be
mr. Limpy he showed up he battled like I
personally don't think he should have
won like I I thought Hadi should have
won I like because I was so you don't
fix it I loved hotties physique because
I'm a guy that's big on conditioning I
liked conditioning I liked I thought to
me like when you look at structure
muscularity and conditioning in
comparison to all three I thought how do
you how do you had more of of that but I
also could see how Bowen that could have
won and I can a hundred percent see how
curry did win so I thought it was that
close I thought it was literally there
just wasn't that one guy that just was
like oh [ __ ] this guy its mover type of
thing so that being said but the
direction that the Olympia has gone
turning over to Dan Solomon who
everybody knows a good friend of mine
but I know the direction he wants to
take things and if you look at all the
stuff that he's doing right now he's
brought Shaq on board and they're doing
a lot of promotional stuff and they're
doing a lot of things you're gonna see
big names in the show this year so
they're it's gonna have heavy hitters in
this you come on flex Luis or were you
doing you got flex Luis in it right we
know that big rama's probably going to
be there we knows the Phils gonna be
there but like it's gonna there's gonna
be some major major guys in this lineup
so whoever wins this it's gonna be a
legitimate win so that's that's a
foregone conclusion
but the part that can take us into the
next level is athletic on it can benefit
across the board now everybody's trying
to act like Oh F Letta Khan is going to
hurt the Olympia I completely disagree
I think athletic Khan is going to
benefit the Olympia because anything
that has the rock involved in it and he
has embraced this industry
he is a bodybuilding fan he is a treaty
trains he lives this type of sport and
he is bringing a different level of you
know like everything that he can do
nobody's been able to do like listen the
what he could do for this sport there
literally hasn't been like Joey Durand
and the things that they've done like
you nobody will do what they did again
because it was just a different time
like that for me was like the golden era
because like he knew all the athletes
and and he was it was like a family like
it was a little bit different but it was
a little bit of a cult type you know
think it wasn't mainstream even though
they wanted it in the Olympics it
probably was just never going to get
there the rock can make it in mainstream
he can put it out there and say look at
what these guys do look at the hard work
they do Kenny they can it take attention
away from the store Olympia or no I mean
I don't think so I mean I think that the
mr. Olympia is the mr. Olympia and I
think that what I think Athletica
athletic on could be huge I think it
could be monster as a point where they
come by 51% of Astral MP or Danelle well
I mean possibly but I think that I think
the key really isn't so much
overshadowing the Olympia I think what
the key is how much attention and how
big athletic con could be
draws that much more you know to the
Olympia in my opinion I well I mean
listen what's going to be interesting to
see what happens because for me again it
goes back to the conversation with what
Dana White it to UFC okay and Dana White
build that Joe Weider cult caught like
top of an environment would you have
seen where people like me who were you
know all boxing and you know following
boxers to all of us and so you know what
I don't even trust any of the judging
movie I'm gonna go watch I got you so I
hope I hope you're right and I hope that
does take place but I also hope I also
hope that somehow someway the
relationship with somebody like a Danny
or a rock it gets deeper in to develop
and promote the next bodybuilders and
take them to the next sub without exit
the head that's what I go with it Dan
seems like a really nice guy when you
even forgot yeah since you're a guy that
wants to do the right thing you know
sometimes we're gonna say some companies
are missing one or two pieces but the
other question I was gonna ask you what
this part was we just talked about the
Dallas we just talked about some of
these stories right what what do you
think needs to be do you think the
bodybuilding world has a black eye
because kidney kidney kidney you know
young you know down low okay
do you think bodybuilding has a black
eye of a the amount of people that have
died or have had issues there and if yes
what do you think needs to happen for it
I mean a different direction the thing
is when you look at the number of people
that have had issues you know it's
pretty small like when you when you look
at it and like I said you know even with
the Flex thing like the Flex thing was
that even the dawn long so I mean that
was one of the guys that that Shawn ray
brought up again he's a hundred percent
aware of what what the deal is with Don
long like if you if you google Don long
you will find out that Don long was born
with one kidney one functioning kidney
he didn't find out about it until 1999
so you know and again like did
bodybuilding like escalate the problem a
hundred percent it escalated the problem
if he would have picked to be a golfer
would he have needed a you know a kidney
transplant so those things are all out
there I think that the biggest issue is
that just like this list like this is
what is being pushed out there because
this is shock value like and I think you
know it's not so much like look there
was the death Momoa died from diuretics
and we know that he died from diuretics
and like you know there's there are
those cases that happened at shows like
there are like but they're far and few
between and in reality most of those are
like all related to something
like the the Momo stories are very
limited and but I think this stuff
because you have a lot of young people
right now that are on the internet and
they're like like trolling the sport you
know realistically yeah and because what
I got to be honest like when I first
seen this list I'm like it's a fake list
like no there's no chance that's a real
list like it's a fake list you like you
know and then you know when when like I
was talking to somebody and they're like
it's actually not a list it's a shopping
list and I'm like okay like I get it now
and it's not for one person it was for
two people and you know so I'm like okay
I got that now and so those are the
things that are out there but this list
being pushed around by 16 year olds and
18 year olds and 19 year olds and all of
these kids and then these kids talking
about this and these kids just like the
sight enhancement so you see all of
these like crazy guys that have just
injected like ridiculous amounts of [ __ ]
in their arms and they look like a
sideshow freak show but where are they
they're on generation iron they're on
all the platforms they're being talked
about on all the podcasts like most
people are making fun of them it's you
up this thing yeah it's the dumbest
looking thing ever since but they're
literally they're like they're there and
when those are the things that are out
there and people pull up bodybuilding
and bam they're that is the general
public looks at that is like what in the
hell they don't see the story of Brandon
Currie flying literally home with the
Sandow and going directly to a school
and talking to kids like you don't see
that very often you see this freak who
has pumped a ton of [ __ ] in his arm for
no reason whatsoever and that's the
stuff because that's what gets shock
value I business mr. Olympia develop
better content with their YouTube
channel and start pumping stuff out
there and start really putting stuff in
our faces so right these types of
stories exactly again that also goes
back to the marketing aspect exactly you
tell the story and I think it was a part
of conversation that we had by the Amish
by the way I am a sue
mink you have spoken to Dan about about
their being on value attainment I'm
assuming I actually haven't so he
doesn't know you're gonna be here
absolutely not he's gonna enjoy yeah no
idea when Sean was here Sean was fully a
you know he sounded like he was all team
you know the run came right prepared to
do you know shots fired and all right I
seem really prepared for the whole thing
but you know again my interest I'm
interested in the sport I mean you see
who's in my ear right that's the reason
why that's their I'm interested in the
sport I think there's a and in me but if
you look at what Dan has done like Dan
has you know he had Mark Wahlberg at the
you know Olympia this year and he's
immediately you know teamed with Shaq
who I think is you know one of the most
visible personalities you know out there
nope and so those things you know are
are huge steps in the right direction
credit to that but I also agree that you
can only do so much there and the only
person that really has the ability to
pull the strings to that next level is
Danny and the rock and they have the
ability to I think take athletes to put
them in front of people that you could
never get in front and that's what it's
going to take it's going to take
somebody whoever if it's Phil Heath or
whoever it is to win potentially
athletic con and to be put out there in
front of people that would never see him
and when he's sitting next to Danny
Garcia and the rock and they're talking
about athletic on and all of the fit you
know physical fitness and stuff all of
the nonsense then is eliminated all
these freaks that are doing the idiotic
stuff is eliminated and it's more of a
positive and that's where everybody has
to go I mean I hope it happens I don't
know it happens I think a benefits the
entire sport if it does happen I I get
asked if Pat do you want to buy him a
stroller up here I don't have the time
but I want a financial firm I don't have
an interest in wanting to buy the
company today I'm in a different state
my life but I wouldn't mind seeing
somebody like them taking me but let me
ask you this 2020 was stolen
what does it look like whitfill he was
it look like without fitfully it comes
back what happens what would the
excitement with the people in your
opinion now you're more team salomon
you're not really team Phil he'd so for
full disclaimer but right no come by
like Phil those are gonna be wrong late
it's funny like I didn't used to really
like him that much I was actually like
when he first came on I was like hi he's
narrow and he's this and that and he
proved me wrong like you know like he I
felt like he had weaknesses and then he
progressed as a bodybuilder and you know
I like the fact that he did that you
know and I mean he'll be the first to
tell you like listen like Chad would
call me out like listen and when I look
good Chad told me I look good when I
look bad
Chad till now look bad and so I'm very
Pro Phil when Phil is a hundred percent
like absolutely if Phil is in the show
it is a better show like it is a better
without a doubt like a hundred percent
okay you know I just you know I think
that's the key like do we see Phil at
the Olympia I think we're gonna see Phil
this year 100 percent you think you're
gonna see 100 percent I think we are
gonna see him I just don't know if we're
gonna see him at the Olympic I agree
with you I let it count
I told yes I totally agree and and
there's been some you you know there's
gonna be some very interesting
announcements being made here pretty
soon but you know I just hope it's not
gonna be one of those things because you
know how sometimes like imagine if I am
right now you know how you said if I had
it my way I would have done whatever I
could to help the other candidates to
help beat Shawn Ray because I wanted to
clean it up exactly so now so so maybe
if mr. Rowland yes a little bit pissed
off would feel before the way he is kind
of in with Chandra maybe Phil is kind of
like dude if I come back they're pumping
up Flex Lewis to kind of subtly give him
the mist rondell give me number two why
would I put my body through this those
are some other things he's got to be
concerned about because there's a lot of
politics there is a lot of politics and
I mean those are things here's the thing
like and I know that's a big topic right
now because Flex Lewis gets an invite
and like their pump and flex Lewis right
it is big time and and here's the thing
that's tough about that like I get the
aspect of he's a to 12 champion and I
believe 100% he deserves an invite
because the Olympia champions literally
carry over full-time so he literally
deserves what no but nobody and he's got
a
beautiful but here's the problem here's
the problem you have you have guys
literally getting ready for the Arnold
right now you have Brandon Currie who's
the reigning mr. Olympia and the last
thing they want to do is prep for a show
with even an inkling of doubt like and I
know exactly what that's like because my
wife prepped for the Olympia who's
without who you're talking about
so like Brandon right yeah Brandon
courage like you know listen you so
here's flex being pumped Pumped now I
have a feeling when we get closer to the
Olympia that's I have a feeling they're
pumping flex right now because I just
invited him and so I think everybody a
little bit I think I think a little bit
everybody's jumping the gun and I think
when it comes right down to it I think
so I think we're gonna have a dominant
winner at the Arnold and I think that
guy is gonna be a major force and I
think that we're going to have Brandon
Curry coming back as like really trying
to prove himself because let's get real
I mean he took a lot of [ __ ] this year
because he didn't beat anybody so he's
now trying to prove himself
you know flex Lewis you know going in
who who has all this I bet he's trying
to prove himself and I think that you
have a situation and who knows what's
gonna happen with rodent-like if Rodin's
court case is over and he's you know
basically you know basically cleared of
all charges I believe that he will be I
think he will be in and so we could
potentially see four or five really good
bodybuilders battle it out on stage I
still don't think it's gonna include
Phil Heath but the ultimate goal you
don't think Phil's gonna hit the stage
this year I think he's gonna hit
athletic on okay without a doubt but at
the end of the day I still think we
could benefit because the ultimate goal
potentially would be whoever wins the
Olympia goes to athletic on now I think
obviously if mr. Olympia then beat you
really scary that's what you just said
it's scary because nothing that means
that let it come becomes do not
necessarily just Thank You Phil he's my
passion people just think if just think
if let's say that Phil Heath bypasses
the I'm just gonna throw this out here
so let's say Phil bypasses the Olympia
and ghost Athletica yeah and let's say
that big RAM he comes in and wins the
Olympia guy and decides he's going to go
to athletic on and then he
beats Phil atletico he just proved that
the mr. Olympia is still by far the top
thing now the flip side of that is if if
he wins the Olympia and goes and gets
beat by Phil then it becomes a different
story is scarier part here's a scarier
part say Phil goes and competes athletic
on he wins he gets a contract with Under
Armour he gets a contract in the movies
he makes nine million dollars
Rahmi then goes and wins the next year
he gets a four and a half million dollar
contract then there's a massive exodus
and and you have to understand
capitalism war no I get that I
understand I don't mind I'm sitting down
he's talking to me he says to me Pat I'm
telling you I got the safest business
there's no one that's gonna put me out
of business
I said Andy Grove the legendary CEO of
Intel in the 80s wrote a book called
only the paranoid survive and it
wouldn't be the smartest little mr.
Olympia can I be parent it was my
absolutely I could be wrong but I got to
tell you like if that scenario played
out it would be the absolute greatest
thing for the athlete and I agree it'll
be humble don't agree you know Phil
Heath making X amount of million whoever
the next person is it would be the
greatest thing because in my opinion
what it would do is it would light a
fire hopefully under some of these guys
and go holy [ __ ] look what Phil just did
because right now that fire is not there
like you can see it like when you're
looking at guy is Wayne Johnson and
banner Garcia are way more sex so into
that world that's a search and it's a
different scenario because like these
guys like right now I think you know I
mean when you go to these shows and when
everybody's talking about like these
guys aren't suffering and these guys
aren't putting in the work and these
guys are out of shape and this and that
does it uh I can tell you that a eight
million dollar Under Armor contract or
whatever you know like all that kind of
money that will literally light a fire
under somebody's ass you know and that's
that's yeah and so and then I'm gonna
give you a bipolar complete opposite
side of it I'd love to see Phil get nine
I just don't know if the political power
people want to see Phil
night because I don't know if they want
the face yeah of nine to be ahead of Lee
Haney or Ronnie because it's almost a
lid I just hope I'm left I'm glad I hope
I'm wrong we're talking nine Olympians
I'm talking nine Olympia yeah yeah that
stuff that's dumb if I'm a guy that's
right now in Olympia I want to see him
come get nine because that's that's
media that's conversation that's talk
but again but but when you think about
it like when you know and then I just
had this conversation when we're looking
at that talk like that guy okay the guy
that's gonna do that and I'm not saying
it's ever gonna be done but even if it's
Phil first he's got to win one more to
eight yeah to get to eight right that
just heisting and then he would need
another one to break nine to break that
like to break that that athlete
literally has to be 100 percent like
that athlete doesn't come in and just
win you know what I mean because even
when ronnie was going for nine and we
and he was already dealing with his back
issues Phil can be a hundred percent I
don't know if he can be a hundred
percent but in two years I'm not sure if
he can be before what he's 40 no yeah
possibly possibly you know but I even
when ronnie was coming in and he was
having the back issues and stuff and you
know I remember having this conversation
with Kimmy it's like you know this is
like nine and and where does he gonna
have to be and I go this will be the
hardest Olympia ever to win I said no
matter even if this one even if he's a
little bit better he's not winning this
one because that separates somebody
that's a monstrosity of an achievement
if anybody could do it maybe Phil maybe
Phil but it would be it'll be crazy well
a chat I think we have to thank Sean ray
for making this happen if it wasn't her
best friend Sean ray you and I are not
sitting at lunch and that a conversation
exactly but also at the same time I I
like the fact that you have the courage
to sit here and take all the questions
you know it's not it's probably the most
open I'm like I'm not the most open guy
just because bodybuilding is typically
not open you know what I'm saying of
course but I think that there's so many
negative things out there
now and like look it's not like we're
hiding something like we all know what's
going on and I think the problem is like
there's so much misdirection and so much
miss you know information out there as
far as like what's actually involved and
stuff and that's why you know like even
Kim was like like how far are you gonna
go with this you know and I go you know
what like I've never like literally
spoke like openly and I'm gonna speak as
open as I possibly can and that's
exactly what you did I think that's
exactly what the audience is gonna
appreciate about this
I think the commentary while you're
watching this obviously you're gonna
share your thoughts below so we can see
what you took away from this I am
assuming there's gonna be a genre camp
that's gonna be here as well and we want
to hear from you as well but chat
appreciate really I know well 24 hours
were coming out I appreciate it thank
you so a different type of a topic for
body but then a lot of you guys have
been asking about it we decided to go a
little bit deeper and obviously he
responded to Sean ray which I'd love to
hear your thoughts please comment below
I got two other interviews I want you to
watch one is with Ronnie Coleman if you
haven't watched it yet and you came here
through suggested videos it's a
phenomenal interview with him or click
over here to watch the interview that
cause Chad Nichols to be a guest on
value taemin which is by genre and again
if you haven't subscribed to the channel
please click here to subscribe thanks
for watching everybody take care bye bye
[Music]